there's this constant breach obviously
with gender ideology there's that breach
with a lot of culture War issues with
the question of gigantic corporations
between the views of the elite class and
the views of the vast majority people
over whom they're ruling and when you
have this kind of mass populist anger
traditionally the elites can try and
appease it or the society can say you
know what let them Riot we'll just
militarize to the teeth we'll give
ourselves every kind power and weapon
that we need so that even if they want
to Riot they'll be crushed immediately I
think the West is choosing that latter
[Music]
path hello everyone watching and
listening today I'm speaking with author
journalist and political commentator
Glenn Greenwall
we discussed the war on Miss and
disinformation how a false social
moralism religious rhetoric conceptions
of safety and false compassion have been
used and misused to reshape the Western
world into a good versus evil polarity
we also explore the human need for meta
narratives the basis of morality and the
case perhaps for God in a world that
offers nihilism and totalitarianism as
Stark
Alternatives all right so I was I was
looking today through um your biography
and and your books and trying to figure
out what we could most productively
discuss and discuss and I thought that
this comment by Rachel madow in 2014
might be a good place to start she
described you in theory um as the
American left's most Fearless political
commentator and so I I have a bunch of
questions about that and the first one
might be what the hell is the American
left and and do you think that that's an
accurate portrayal of you and I I I'm
not being I'm not being smart asking
that question like it isn't obvious to
me at all how the
political lines are drawn now I'm up in
the air about it constantly
so were you the American left's most
Fearless political commentator are you
still and what do you think the left is
one thing I can tell you for certain is
that that is not something she would say
in 2023 my recollection is that was
actually a little bit earlier I think it
might have been 2009 or 10 at the start
of the Obama Administration when I
became a very vocal critic of the Obama
Administration and there weren't a lot
of people who were willing to take the
same critique that was being applied to
George Bush and Dick Cheney regarding
the war on terrorist and the assault on
civil liberties in the name of the war
on terror and apply it to Obama even
though Obama not only continued many of
those policies that he campaigned on the
vow to uproot but extended a lot of them
strengthened a lot of them and suddenly
people on the left either lost interest
in that or decided that actually it was
now justifiable given that it was now in
the hands of a benevolent leader rather
than some swaggering Evangelical like
George Bush or this kind of caricature
of capitalism like Dick Cheney their
views the actual policy just switched
overnight and mine did not one of the
things though that I always said from
the very beginning you know I started
writing about politics in 2005 I did so
overwhelmingly as a reaction to the war
on terror I was writing not as a
journalist but more as a constitutional
lawyer that was more my interest I was
saying things like Americans detained on
American soil and then detained for
years without charges just based on this
declaration they were enemy combatants
with no trial no hearing just based on
the say so of the executive branch I
always thought it was odd that that kind
of perspective got me labeled as
somebody on the left because from my
perspective I was defending values like
due
process uh Free Speech a free press you
know I was concerned about the erosion
of civil liberties I never really
thought of those as farle values but it
got interpreted as that because at the
moment it took found expression as being
critical of George Bush and Dick Cheney
and the perception was only people on
the left were were doing that so where
Rachel mad's ideas came from I haven't
changed my views on any of those issues
at all now defense of civil liberties
opposition to censorship codes as
right-wing you know just 15 years later
and I think a lot of times people
consider me on the right even though as
I said My Views really haven't changed
but I think that's where that's where
that comes from okay so yeah in 2006 you
wrote how would a Patriot Act defending
American values from a president run a
mck and that was GW bush one of the many
presidents who've run a mark but
certainly um that was what you were
writing about okay so that's how you got
identified initially as on the left now
you started a First Amendment litigation
law firm in 1996 and I I guess so I'm
kind of curious about why that was why
specifically concentrating on the First
Amendment and then I'm interested in how
that Tangled in with your Rising
suspicion and apprehension about the
Restriction of civil liberties after
9/11
when I got out of law school I worked
for about 18 months at one of the major
Wall Street law firms and knew
immediately that was not for me I knew
from the start it wasn't for me I grew
up pretty poor the lur of a big paycheck
like that was something I just wanted to
kind of get a taste of I also wanted to
demystify Wall Street you know kind of
enter it and at the end of the day those
firms are filled with very
competent crafty smart lawyers and I
knew I would learn a lot and I did but
but 18 months was the most I could
endure what I really wanted to do you
know I think my childhood Heroes I was
sort of steeped in the politics of the
70s and 80s this was the time when the
ACLU was defending the right of
neo-nazis to March through skoki a town
of Holocaust Survivors based obviously
on the principal these were Jewish
leftist lawyers at the ACLU defending
obviously not the Nazi party but the
principal that marginalized groups in
particular need to defend free speech I
always viewed censorship as a tool of
the establishment as a tool of authority
that was used to silence and suppress
marginalized voices dis dissidents and
the like and so the desire to use the
tools that had gained in law school in
defense of those kinds of political
values those kinds of causes was
something that was probably at the end
of the day what made me go to law school
more than anything else I certainly
didn't want to defend Goldman Sachs and
insurance companies the way I was doing
and so I was able to
the I think one of the very first
prominent cases I took was there was
this
Neo-Nazi uh leader in Illinois who was
quite smart he went to law school he
passed the bar exam and he applied for
admission to the Illinois Bar so he
could practice law and the Illinois Bar
rejected his application on the grounds
of moral uh Fitness and character which
is what they used to do to communist in
1950s and 60s they were bar from
practicing law on the grounds that they
lacked moral Fitness in a lot of Supreme
Court cases that established these
Landmark First Amendment cases said you
cannot bar people from professions
because of their political ideology
however pricious that ideology might be
and so now to watch that happen from the
other side you know kind of a left-wing
or liberal attempt to Define moral
character and fitness not on whether you
steal from people or whether you assault
people but whether or not you have the
right political views was very
disturbing to me so I represented him I
represented his quote unquote church and
a couple of other cases that were
designed to implant in the law this the
seeds of the censorship regime and kind
of became a specialist in those kinds of
cases so well a couple of comments about
that the first is um I don't know what
the situation is in the United States
but the professional colleges in Canada
are increasingly taking a restrictive
view of Fitness to practice I mean I've
been
subject to I think 13 charges
essentially by my professional governing
board uh they dropped seven of them
recently although they didn't explain
why they dropped those seven and kept
the other six but all of the other six
are almost all of them none of which by
the way were made by clients of mine are
a consequence of my direct criticisms of
political figures and so I don't know
what the situation is in the United
States but I know that um in Canada the
The Professional governing boards have
really uh taken a what would you say
they've allowed free speech for
professionals to take a back seat and it
strikes me as extremely dangerous
because I don't see exactly what the
members of the general public are how
they're going to be served by therapists
or Physicians who are too terrified to
say what they think and I mean I've had
dozens of Physicians tell me even more
than psychologists even though my battle
is with the psychology um governing
board that they're so terrified of their
of their Professional Organization
that's the Ontario College of Physicians
that they won't say what they think
about all sorts of things so I don't
know what's the situation like in the US
on the professional regulatory board
front well in theory it's supposed to be
more difficult in the United States to
do those sorts of things because of the
First Amendment and on some level it is
mildly more difficult but they are
really finding all kinds of ways to
circumvent that we lost that case for
example I lost that case they did not
when the the right for this Neo-Nazi
leader to practice law though it was
basically on jurisdictional and
Technical grounds so that's oftentimes
the way they'll do it is you can see
these judges very ideologically
motivated especially in United States
nobody wants to admit they believe in
the virtues of censorship because it's
inculcated in the American Spirit that
anything that is called censorship is
kind of instinctively or reflexively
wrong so it is a little bit that the
first amendment is a real barrier in the
United States but I regard the kinds of
Trends you're describing that happened
to you in the west more generally I know
Canada is one of the worst places for it
I used to write a lot about the hate
speech laws um I remember Mark Stein was
dragged before one of those tribunals uh
there was Ezra Levant as well and I
remember back in 20072 2008 when I was
be called being called as leftist I was
defending them and a lot of people on
both the left and the right I think were
surprised but I could see this coming
and now it's so much worse you know all
throughout Western Europe um
increasingly in North America I lived in
Brazil for a long time as well where
these censorship values are people don't
even pretend to believe in free speech
even though Brazil is part of the
democratic world and and Western Europe
is looking toward Brazil as a kind of
laboratory for how part Brazil can go
particularly the interest is in
censoring the internet but beyond that
you see people now being excluded from
the financial services industry people
can't open bank accounts or use PayPal
or any of these these these mechanisms
that in Modern Life we need to generate
an income and sustain our families and
pay our bills purely on ideological
grounds there's not even a pretense as
you said there's no patient complaint in
your case it's clearly designed to say
you're unfit to
practice uh psychology because of your
political ideology and that is to me the
most dangerous Trend in the west Beyond
any other because that not only punishes
people and just ways but it also breeds
a conformist Society the message is very
clear we're self-interested beings and
if we see that there's a lot of rewards
for espousing establishment pities and a
lot of punishments for questioning them
or defying them obviously a lot of
people are going to be motivated to be
as conformist as possible and we're
going to become even more conformist as
a society if that continues and that I
think is a huge loss just of the human
Spirit of the of the potential of human
life to lose the to engage in critical
thinking and to question and ER and to
challenge these are the things for me at
least that make life valuable well also
you know you you when you were
formulating your defense of of free
speech you mentioned the fact that
marginalized voices let's say minority
voices need to be heard but I would
extend that too I mean I think often the
majority voice isn't heard and is
subject to censorship and I think that's
happening more and more often in the
west and but there's also something else
you know because people might be leery
let's say of your willingness to defend
neo-nazis at least to defend their right
to you know be as obnoxious as they
generally are but it's also the case as
far as I can tell and I really saw this
in Canada like back in the 1980s we went
after this guy named Ern zundel for hate
speech and this was the first emergence
we like to Pioneer these things in
Canada by the way we pioneered banking
counseling for example thanks to our
prime minister and who basically
demolished our International reputation
as consequence of that even though
Canadians don't know it yet anyways we
went after this guy Ern dundle back in
the 1980s on hate speech and he was a
Neo-Nazi type and U you know everybody
was up in arms about this hard hat
wearing dimwit who proclaimed that the
Holocaust didn't occur and all these you
know idiot shibis of the of the radical
um Neo-Nazi right-wing and uh and he did
get he did get pillared for what he had
done I think by an early human rights
tribunal and I thought at the time that
that was extraordinarily unfortunate
because it's first of all because I knew
even then that persecuting someone
paranoid generally is a very bad idea
because you give truth to their paranoid
claims that way and second if you take
these people like zundel and you drive
them
underground then you don't know what the
hell they're up to and part of the
reason that we need a culture of free
speech is so that we can observe very
carefully what The Fringe is up to
constantly and keep an eye on their
machinations and part of the reason that
that actually turns out to be useful is
because most people who are highly
pathological can't help telling you what
they're going to do and so if you have a
space for free dialogue you can really
keep an eye on the people who would
otherwise destabilize things you drive
them underground at your your peril as
far as I'm concerned so yeah and
precisely and I agree with that entirely
that on pragmatic grounds sensorship
makes no sense from the perspective of
those censoring not only because you
lose the opportunity to hear what
they're thinking see what they're doing
but so often you turn these people into
martyr I mean in the United States you
have the right to wear a swastika on
your arm if you so choose because the
first amendment gives you that right but
if you do that you're going to be laugh
at you're going to be regarded as a joke
you're going to be you know social scorn
works so much better than trying to
prevent people from speaking social
scorn isolates people it turns them into
an object of mockery you try and you
know the neonazi leader that I was
defending that I referenced earlier he
was a loser you know he had maybe 10
followers who were all kind of various
forms of sociopaths and psychotics just
kind of like aimless kids who were
looking for some meaning these are not
menacing people in the sense of
gathering some movement or being
strategically impressive by turning them
into Martyrs by making them seem like
they're so much more powerful than they
were because now you have to suppress
them their power and strength grows that
attracts people especially younger
people who see transgression as
something
appealing they you know I think the best
thing that ever happened to myopolis for
example was when the left started trying
to prevent him from speaking on college
campuses that's what made Milo a hero to
the right they turned him into that and
obviously now Milo has largely
disappeared in part because he but more
so because he lost a lot of his funding
from the right but what made him and so
many others like that stronger was the
attempt to silence than the attempt to
censor them and I look in other
countries where it's illegal to question
Holocaust pieties most of Western Europe
in Brazil I think in Canada as well and
those people can attract a lot more
followers than for example in the US
they can because everything is open in
the US and the idea is well at least
used to be you're free to express that
view no one's going to try and stop you
and social stigma social scorn for me is
a much stronger way of marginalizing a
nefarious ideology than having the state
or corporate
power you know invoked in order to to
crush
it starting a business can be tough
especially knowing how to run your
online storefront thanks to Shopify it's
easier than ever Shopify is the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from the
launch your online shop stage all the
way to the did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is there to help
you grow our marketing team uses Shopify
every day to sell our merchandise and we
love how easy it is to add more items
ship products and track conversions
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 36% better
compared to other leading Commerce
platforms no matter how big you want to
grow Shopify gives you everything you
need to take control and take your
business to the next level sign up for a
$1 per month trial period at shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com jbp now to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're at that's shopify.com
[Music]
jbp Yeah well yeah well the other thing
too of course when you get that EXT ion
of state power and corporate power
there's no telling whatsoever what
direction it's eventually going to turn
in I mean I um I interviewed Robert F
Kennedy Jr a couple of weeks ago for my
podcast and um the YouTube took it down
and this was really shocking to me I
must say first of all I thought it would
provoke more of a storm of outrage in
the United States because you guys were
obsessively concerned for three years
about Russian collusion in relationship
to election interference which all
turned out as far as I could tell to be
nothing but rubbish or very little more
than that but um here we have a large
corporation essentially Google actively
interfering with an ongoing presidential
campaign by a Democrat not by a
Republican and yet that seemed to go by
with very little notice and so the and
this is really quite
staggering to me even though I'm already
aware that the Democrats are nowhere
near as terrified as the radical of the
radical left as they need to be the fact
that the censorship could already
proceed to the point where it was
actually a Democrat who was being
censored doesn't seem to register with
the Democrats who don't seem to
understand that in the wrong hands and
that could be at any moment that power
could be used precisely against them and
so and then one more thing and I'll get
your comments more generally on this
I've been following the UN Twitter feed
more recently even though that's very
dismal and disheartening thing to do and
one of the things that I see there
that's really I say would say top of the
list for appalling International
globalist utopians is the fact that
they're constantly prattling on about
hate speech and disinformation and
enjoining the people who are following
them online to be very careful about
what they share and and adopting this
idea that a top down centralized
apparatus can be used to separate let's
say fact from fiction which would be
lovely if it was true but has never been
true and never will be and so what do
you think's accounting for this how do
you understand the mounting pressure
that's faced by the this Bedrock
commitment to free speech what the hell
do you think's going
on so first of all I agree with you
completely about Google's censoring of
RFK Jr in a lot of I mean this is you're
talking about somebody not only from one
of the most storied political families
in the United States and not eight
Generations removed his father was the
Attorney General of the United States
his uncle was the United States
President he spent most of his life as a
mainstream Environmental Lawyer he
endorsed Hillary Clinton in 2008 we're
not talking here about a leader of a
Neo-Nazi Church we're talking about
somebody who has spent his entire life
in the American mainstream who now is
being silenced doing an interview with
one of the
most listened to podcast host in
yourself and somebody who is pulling at
20% 20% of Democratic party voters say
they intend to vote for this person for
president and the most powerful
corporations or one of the richest and
most powerful corporations ever to exist
Google sweeps in and says this is
something that you are not permitted to
be heard and what happened was what
always is the tactic of sensors is they
always pick it test case in the
beginning that they believe is someone
who is
sufficiently hated or disliked so that
everybody will acess to the president
simply because their emotions for that
person are so high so the first person
to really be deep platformed in this
collusive effort by Silicon Valley was
Alex Jones and Peter teal was on the
board of Facebook at the time Mark Andre
in Silicon Valley and a few other people
stood up at the time and said no matter
how much you hate Alex Jones this
President is going to work its way
slowly maybe not even so slowly to
expand into the kinds of voices that you
probably think shouldn't be censored and
by the point that you cheer the
president in the first instance because
you allow your emotional dislike for
this person to outweigh your rational
capacities it will be too late the
president's already implemented and then
you're left to just bicker about its
application rather than the principle
itself and that's precisely what has
happened they began quickly censoring
mainstream conservative voice voes Deon
Nunes went to rumble in part to escape
from Google censorship and then a huge
stream of people did as well one of the
most shocking things that happened along
those lines Rand Paul questioned a
couple of
epidemiologists scientist who were
testifying before the US Senate about
the possible efficacy of ior mechon and
other alternative medication for coid it
was a senate hearing a hearing in the
United States Senate Rand Paul put it on
his YouTube channel was a excerpt of
this hearing and Google decided that was
something that ought not to be heard as
well so as for the question of why this
is happening I think it's twofold I
think one is that Millennials and now
gen Z are very much steeped in the idea
that the gravest danger is not
empowering centralized authority to
dictate what we have to think and what
we can and can't hear but
instead is the danger that comes from
ideas that they dislike and as you said
it is true a lot of times the ideas that
are being censored are ideas held by the
majority I still regard them though as
marginalized ideas because the what
matters more than the numbers is often
who's in power and the elite the people
who are the guardians of elite discourse
have views that are increasingly at odds
with the majority of the population and
those are the views that get passed on
as from on high as kind of the mandated
Orthodoxy and the views held by the
majority of people end up being treated
as marginalized or dissent views that
get silen simply by virtue of the fact
that the majority has no power and the
elite has so much power so I think part
of it is just this generational cultural
sense that began with Millennials has
gotten worse with Gen Z if you look at
polling out do you see this clearly that
free speech is not really a Paramount
value anymore that there are other
values in there views that outweigh Free
Speech or the the right to have debate
be heard but I really think the
accelerant to everything was the
election of Donald Trump I think Donald
Trump's election was such a gift to the
American establishment because it
enabled them to depict Donald Trump not
as what he was which is a continuation
of the American tradition as a symptom
of the failures of the neoliberal elite
of the anger that neoliberalism has
produced all around the world they
instead depicted him as this kind of
singular unprecedented evil this never
before encountered Menace and threat to
all things decent including democratic
values and if you can convince people
that they're not just engaged in
ordinary political conflict but instead
kind of an existential overarching
historic Battle of good versus evil kind
of like giving it religious overtones
which is what our politics has has
absorbed on some level everything and
anything becomes justifiable in the name
of Prosecuting that cause and a lot of
people got convinced that the evils of
trump and his movement were so
overarching that everything had to be
thrown out the window the role of
Journalism the virtue of free speech the
idea of due process they really believe
they're they're confronting this
insurrectionary criminal fascist
movement that wants to install a white
supremacist dictatorship This Is How
They think and if you convince enough
people of that and that is what the
Elite Class really believes I don't
think they're pretending to believe that
I think they genuinely believe that
they're constantly reinforcing each
other in this sort of her behavior
it's not that far of a leap then to
start saying things like well however
bad censorship is or however bad
disinformation is or however bad
punishing people is without due process
the threat that we're combating is even
worse and therefore the me means just
the ends justify the means um You
probably saw that Sam Harris video that
went viral where he was asked about the
hunter Biden disinformation campaign
that emanated from the CIA they just
lied to the public and said that Hunter
Biden laptop was Russian disinformation
it came from the CIA corporate media
repeated it big Tac adopted it it was a
massive scam that they perpetrated on
the American public right before the
2020 election one of the biggest
journalistic scandals I think in in the
history of our country and when Sam
Harris was asked about that being the
kind of Cogan candid thinker he is he
essentially gave voice to the idea that
I still think the evils of
trump outweigh everything that even
lying and censorship of that kind is
Justified in the name of the cause of
stopping Trump and I think that has
become the predominant ethos of our
Elite Class and that's where the
censorship support is coming from do you
do you see it as well as uh part of the
Cascade of processes that began to make
themselves manifest after 911 and this
is partly when you got interested in the
clamp down on civil liberties and you
know one of the things that I observed
at that time which I don't think has
gone away in the least was the
transformation of airports into microf
fascist States and I thought that was a
really bad idea because by treating
everyone like a potential perpetrator
which is exactly what's happened in the
airports and has never gone away you
essentially train people to adopt that
mindset because everybody goes through
airports and once it's okay there well
then why isn't it okay everywhere I mean
there's lots of buildings in the UK now
where you basically have to undergo an
airport style search before you go into
the building and of course you have to
do that in the many of the government
buildings in Washington which I also
think is an appalling idea but but so so
is there an additional thread that's
promoting this top down clamp down that
do you think is a consequence of what
occurred after 911 yeah I think it's a
really important observation I was in
Manhattan on 911 I lived and worked in
in New York at the time I remember as
well as anybody the vividness of that
trauma it was a very traumatic event it
was frightening it was
terrible I understand that that people's
fears were activated in a way that made
them be willing to support things they
never would have supported otherwise I
ended up supporting things that I
ordinarily would have recoiled from like
most people in the United States
did it's just that even with the war on
terror even with an attack that
cataclysmic that just wiped out 3,000
lives in one of the most horrible ways
imaginable I think while the extremism
that emerged from that I remember nuk
ingr wrote an article in 2006 advocating
the First Amendment be amended to
constrict free speech in the name of
stopping Muslim extremism or whatever he
was calling it um jihadism or Sharia
law those ideas ultimately didn't go as
far as they might have because the sense
of what American democracy means kind of
got reawakened and I think people did
start drawing lines and President Obama
ended up winning in 2008 on a pledge to
close Guantanamo and reverse the kind of
more extremist measures of the war on
terror even though he didn't out that
that was what his campaign that was
successful was based on but I think what
you're saying about the airport is
exactly right if you go look at the
debates in the 90s after the Oklahoma
City bombing the bombing at the Oklahoma
City Courthouse that Timothy McVey was
convicted of perpetrating there was an
attempt by the Clinton Administration to
usher in a lot of these same extreme
measures that ended up being implemented
after 911 they wanted for example the
keys to the internet a back door to all
of the encryption used by the internet
and the Republican party including
people like John Ashcraft who became
George Bush's attorney general in the
wake of 911 and the champion a lot of a
lot of these civil arities assaults led
the way and said we're not giving the
federal government the ability to read
our Communications to spy on our
conversations this is too anathema to
the American way of life and and so
quickly after 9/11 the exact same
faction in the Republican party and
American conservatism traumatized by the
attack of 911 again for understandable
reasons but ultimately went so far in
implementing what became an
authoritarian mentality and if you go to
the airport of course all of us now are
so acclimated to it it seems normal but
the idea that everybody just so
dutifully takes off their shoes and
takes off their belt and the climate
there is you just do what you're told
you know it's kind of it seems trivial
and it's the form of it's a kind of
petty authoritarianism no one's being
imprisoned for it no one's being shot
but what it is is it's almost more
Insidious because of that because
exactly as you say it started
conditioning people that in the name of
safety we need to unquestioningly obey
Authority kind of submit to whatever
humiliations whatever orders were told
to do and to watch the american
conservative movement that was so
steadfast in their opposition to the
idea of federal government power in the
1990s immediately turn around and start
meekly taking off their shoes at
airports and doing everything that they
were told and going through these
machines in the name of safety I think
was was quite transformative and I do
think it started training Americans
to accept the kinds of infringements on
their autonomy in the name of safety
that even just a couple of years earlier
would have been Unthinkable well you you
know what I think maybe the critics on
the left um I'll specify them to begin
with have always been concerned that the
fundamental threats to Liberty and let's
say equality would emerge as a
consequence of greed and the desire for
power you know and it's obviously the
case that there are valid criticisms
that can be levied against gigantic
organizations that tilt towards
regulatory capture with regards both
both to their greed and their desire for
undeserved power but I think that the
left has radically underestimated the
threat that fear poses to Liberty and I
guess that's probably true of the right
as well and and what what you're laying
out is a a case where the excuse for
interfering with fundamental Liberties
is always something like a higher or is
very frequently something like um a
compassionate concern for safety and so
maybe it's the neo-nazis that we have to
be afraid of or maybe it's the Muslim
jihadists and or maybe it's the bloody
pandemic or maybe it's the looming
environmental apocalypse but there's
always some terrible catastrophe that's
looming so intently that this is finally
the time when an assault on our civil
liberties to be can be justified and my
sense of that is that the reason we made
these rights axiomatic or actually the
reason they they are axiomatic not that
we made them that way is because there
isn't any circumstances under which
there's a better approach than to leave
people the hell alone to let them say
what they need to say and that's partly
because you know one of the things I
think conservatives do extremely badly
is to try to protect Free Speech as if
it's just another Freedom you know it's
like a honic freedom well of course you
get to say what you want to say because
you want to say it and it's you know you
enjoy it and annoying not to be allowed
to say it and that's not really the
issue here at all the issue is that for
most people there's no difference
between speaking and
thinking so and Mo and even for those
that small number of people who can in
fact think and that's actually quite
rare most of those people think by
speaking they just speak internally I
mean you can speak you can think in
images too but really detailed thought
really requires words and so freedom of
speech is exactly equivalent to freedom
of thought and the reason that you think
is so that you don't do stupid things um
carelessly right so there's this great
it was Alfred North Whitehead who
famously said that we think so that our
thoughts can die instead of us and if
thought is the process by which we re
renew our misapprehensions and adapt to
the World At Large and transform our
institutions if you interfere with free
speech you doom your institutions to
stagnation and and uh corruption and so
and so and so then you have to say well
if you're going to be afraid let's say
you're afraid of the coming
environmental apocalypse you might want
to be equally afraid of the measures
that people take to deal with that
apocalypse that are going to interfere
with freedom of speech because that'll
interfere with our ability to adapt and
that'll be far worse than anything we
can conjure up on the environmental
front and so I think that's part of the
reason that these rights are
self-evident right is that the whole
bloody game will grind to a halt if we
ever allow them to be interfered with
and that means ever and that basically
means your neurotic catastrophe is not
sufficient justification for your desire
to infringe on my free speech I don't
care what your bloody emergency is you
know I think this is something I've come
to conceptualize better over the years
and it's very much based in
the psychological Dynamic you're
describing George orbal has this preface
I believe it was 1984 I'm me to I don't
remember the exact details now and
originally when the book was published
where this preface that the preface was
intended for the preface ended up not
being published it was right around the
time of World War II and it
was kind of considered heretical because
its argument was that we think about
tyranny in these melodramatic terms that
suppression that despotism means that if
you say something against the government
armed men in black suits Black costumes
show up at your house and put guns to
your head and haul you off to prison
when in reality the much more effective
kind of despotism is not the use of
brute force in that way it's really the
transformation of the Mind the prison
ends up being something that's
constructed inside of your brain through
extremely effective propaganda which in
turn requires that that propaganda never
be questioned if you can control a
population based on how they think you
essentially eliminate the possibility of
descent so you can make descent on paper
legally
permissible but anyone who does disent
will be so instantaneously marginalized
because of the efficacy of propaganda
that it's a much more effective way of
controlling human beings because you're
controlling the thoughts that they have
and that in turn requires the ability to
ensure you control the flow of
information and this is the thing that I
find so alarming was if you go and look
at the literature in the mid 1990s about
the Advent of the internet I think
people in Silicon Valley really had this
libertarian ethos they thought they were
actually producing a technology that was
going to be
revolutionary the the spirit behind it
was we're going to emancipate people
from centralized State and corporate
control they're going to be able to
communicate people are going to be able
to communicate with one another without
relying on the mediation of giant
corporations which in turn are
controllable by the state it was kind of
this wild west Frontier free of control
free of
Regulation and when I worked with Edward
Snowden and we did the Snowden reporting
in 2013 in the archive that he provided
to me as I began to look at it revealed
that in fact the internet had become the
exact polar opposite it become the
single greatest means of coercion and
control ever invented in human history
because the ability to control the flow
of information and to monitor what every
what all of us are doing not just what
we're doing in terms of where we're
going but in terms of what we're reading
and what we're saying in private or what
we think is in private and therefore
what we're thinking what kind of
personality is shaping us and the ideas
that are motivating us and then the
ability that that is accompanied by that
knowledge to be ble to then control and
manipulate it creates this kind of
closed propaganda system that is
infinitely more powerful than say having
a stacei that is able to read
everybody's email everybody's mail in
East Germany or have their neighbors
report on them in fact during the
Snowden reporting there were ex agents
of the stacei who were saying this
enables the state to do things we never
dreamed of being able to do you know
when it was why I don't know if you
remember but there was one of the
reports was about about how the NSA was
spying on Angela Merkel at the time the
chancellor of Germany she grew up in
East Germany under the Stasi behind Yan
curtain and she was particularly enraged
by it by all account she called Obama in
a rage and said essentially that this is
what the Stasi tried to do and
technologically were kind of impeded
from doing there were workarounds to it
if you were a dissident in East Germany
there were dissidents in in in in behind
the Iron Curtain in in in communist uh
Soviet communism whereas this kind of
makes
impossible and increasingly what it's
relied on is as I was saying earlier I
think these Elites who believe that
Trump is the singular evil that
everything is Justified in the name of
stopping him I say they genuinely
believe it because even people who are
reasonably intelligent who have been
educated all of that are very prone to
propaganda propaganda is a weapon that
has been developed over many decades
that is designed to cater specifically
to what our needs are psychologically it
creates a reward system a punishment
system it's very powerful I think all of
us probably have the experience of
having been propagandized and one way or
the other where we come to realize we
believe something that we've never
really critically assessed that we've
kind of just absorbed in the ethos I
know I've had that experience many times
before and I think that is really what
the censorship regime is about it's not
necessarily to
punish dissident although that is part
of it it's really to ensure that people
are only getting exposed to a flow of
information that serves the interest of
a small Elite so that you don't have to
kill and punish dissidents you just
eliminate dissent and the few people who
are for whatever reason kind of
resisting it end up just so marginalized
that it doesn't matter anyway and on
some level it's almost better to have
them because it casts the illusion that
there's still some lingering
Freedom the October 15th tax deadline
has just passed I know many of you might
be dreading the stress of filing your
taxes filing your taxes can be a long
excruciating process but if you fail to
file you'll start to pile penalties on
top of your tax debt that's why you need
to check out tax Network USA the team at
tax Network USA has a track record of
success they've reduced tax debts for
numerous clients totaling over $1
billion whether you're looking at a
$110,000 or $1 million tax debt they can
help you with the settlement it doesn't
matter if you haven't filed in 1 year 5
years or even a Whole Decade tax Network
USA is equipped to secure the best
settlement for you the expert attorneys
in tax professionals at tax Network USA
can help resolve all tax cases no matter
how they started don't let tax debt
control your life any longer take the
first step toward resolving your tax
issues by visiting tax Network
usa.com Peterson that's tax Network
usa.com Peterson
today now you you made reference in our
conversation here to the religious
overtones let's say that accompanied um
claims that Trump for example was you
know the sum of all evil and going to
instantiate a white supremacist
totalitarian state that would rule to
the end of time and you wrote a book in
2007 a tragic Legacy how a good versus
evil mentality destroyed the bush
presidency so I want to delve into that
for a minute and share with you some
thoughts I've been developing and and
you tell me think about them okay I'm
still working this out so you know
there's a gospel phrase that you're to
Render unto Caesar what is Caesar and
unto God what is gods and the idea there
that is a one of the ideas there is that
there are separate conceptual domains
for different kinds of
concerns and that the and so the way I
read that at least in part I I'll tell
you a backstory you know now and then
when I was working as a clinician I
would have clients tell tell me things
that were truly terrible like
multi-generational murderous terrible
you know uh long family histories of
hidden sexual uh um abuse uh lies so
deep that you can hardly imagine them
way out on the pale Beyond The Pale
right and I for me that was the land of
Good and Evil and one of the things that
would happen if I was discussing things
that were deeply affecting enough to
give the people who had had the
experience of post-traumatic stress
disorder is that the con the tenor of
the conversation and the language itself
would almost inevitably become religious
and it helped me understand that part of
what religious language does is enable
us to conduct a dialogue about about
what's truly malevolent right beyond the
political and so and that made me wonder
you know if if the religious collapses
so that you can no longer Render unto
God what is Gods let's say because that
entire belief system disappears then
maybe the maybe everything that should
be attributed to God so to speak is now
played out in the political realm is
that you get a collapse of the religious
into the political and the reason that
that's a catastrophe is because then you
can no longer conduct the political as
political it degenerates into a war of
good against evil and but but a very
also a very very I would say
unsophisticated War so I'll I'll just
close with this and then you can comment
if you would so one of the things that
happens as the
judeo-christian Corpus of of what would
you say of conceptualization of good and
evil as it
develops the notion is is that spiritual
battle between good and evil is
something that should be conducted on an
individual basis and within so that if
you want to constrain evil you don't
search for it in the external world
because that can make you a persecutor
and an accuser you attempt to bind its
manifestation in the confines of your
own life and that's partly what takes it
out of the political realm and so if you
don't do that and it collapses into the
political then you start looking for
demonic enemies everywhere to account
for malevolence and the problem with
that is that it turns you into a
sensorial self-righteous persecutor now
you wrote a whole book about you know
the the the the good versus evil
mentality destroying the bush presidency
and you talked about the religious
overtones that are associated for
example with with justification of
censorship on the oh my God this is
finally the apocalyptic threat basis
like I'm curious about what you think of
the conceptual scheme that I just laid
forward that we need a language for
dealing with good and evil per se and a
separate political langu language and if
we don't keep those separate well one
collapses into the other it doesn't
disappear yeah you know it's interesting
I um as I listen to that you know I mean
I grew up uh without a lot of religion
like many people these days in the west
do um my grandparents were steeped in
Judaism but not very you know ex not it
wasn't very extreme it was more cultural
I would say religious my parents less so
and then by the time uh we got to my
brother and myself it was almost
non-existent and you know like in early
adulthood I kind of considered that a
source of Pride like so many people do
it's a pmark of sophistication and
modernity that you've discarded these
archaic conceptions and we're now you
know Advanced and all of that and
obviously technologically we are more
advanced than the generations that came
before us but I think a lot of times
with that comes a certain huus that
because we're more technologically
advanced it means we're more advanced in
every way and one of the things that I
have worked hard is to lose that hubris
and I think you know for me when I see
people who believe in censorship believe
in the idea that certain views are so
wrong they that it ought to be
prohibited to me what's driving that
more than anything is hubris because the
whole history of humanity is error what
is considered proven truth and one
generation is then regarded as Grievous
error the next that's true across every
field of discipline and morality and
ethics and the idea that somehow we've
escaped from that and we are now no
longer prone to error that we have
apprehended truth that is just so
absolute that no one should be even
allowed to question it it's just never
an Impulse I ever have no M and I
believe in a lot of things passionately
very strongly it's not like I walk
around doubting everything I just never
would find the level of arrogance to
believe that my convictions even the
ones I hold most strongly are so
self-evidently and permanently true that
any questioning of them should be
prohibited barred and I think huis is at
the root of that I think the same is
true with the idea of religion there is
a reason I think that human beings
across Millennia and across culture and
across every other conceivable line have
sought out religion I believe something
we need it's intrinsic to us whether you
want to call it religious or spiritual
however you describe it it's something
that is a part of us and that we're
going to seek out one way or the other
because it I believe is a human need
it's something I've started looking for
myself as I get older now that I have
kids it's something that has become a
bigger part of my life and if you don't
have that in the form that people have
traditionally had it with the
established religions of Judaism or
Christianity or Islam or Hinduism or any
of even smaller you know more more
modern religions like Mormonism I think
people are going to find a way to to to
express that and these days they use
Politics as their vehicle for it and
that is what's so dangerous is exactly
what you're describing because the
fanaticism and the faith and the
righteousness that comes from that
religious and spiritual expression can
be extremely dangerous if imported into
politics which isn't about as you say
for me this religious and spiritual
exploration is about what we do
internally you know how we understand
ourselves and our relationship to the
universe and whether there's something
bigger than ourselves and our purpose
it's a very
introspective and personal Endeavor
whereas politics is about wielding power
in a way that controls and influences
the lives of other people and if you
import this Rel religious component into
it and cease having empathy for other
people's experiences and ideas and just
are always convinced that whoever is on
the other side of your tribe is
intrinsically evil and you're
intrinsically good again it's going to
devolve into that ends justifi the means
mentality and in politics that is
historically an extremely dangerous way
of navigating the world so do you think
so I've been talking to Douglas Murray
about this um topic quite extensively I
would over a number of years and Douglas
was raised in a more religious family
than you were a Christian family um and
his parents were Avid church attenders
but he dispensed with all of that and
toyed for a while even with uh explicit
Allegiance with the you know with the
Hitchens Dawkins Harris um crowd um
dennet as well the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse
but Douglas has become more more
convinced
that the humanist Endeavor cannot
maintain its ethos without it being
embedded in an underlying let's say
narrative metaphysics which is for all
intents and purposes a religious
framework and the religious framework
also you know it it it always borders on
the Transcendent and the unknowable I
suppose that's a good way of thinking
about it so Carl Jung thought for
example that the psychoanalyst he sort
of believed that our rationality was
necessarily bounded by the domain of the
dream right if you think about how we
adapt to the world we have our explicit
ways of representing the world that can
be encapsulated semantically and those
would be our statable
propositions but that's never complete
right and so outside of that is
everything we don't know and from the
perspective of Yung and and the
psychoanalyst who adopted his Viewpoint
the dream was the mediator between what
we knew explicitly and what we did not
yet know it was a buffer zone and the
the Transcendent characters of the
Dreamscape were essentially deities and
religious figures and that strikes me as
correct I think that's in keeping with
how we what we Now understand about how
the brain functions and about how we
process information when we first come
across it um as anomalous for example
but it does beg the question you know
Douglas has told me pretty
straightforwardly that he thinks that
any ethical system that isn't grounded
in a Transcendent metaphysics whatever
that means is going to degenerate into a
propagandistic
ideology and well I'm I'm wondering like
are those thoughts that you said that
you've been seeking more now at this
stage in your life than you had been
previously do those sorts of Reflections
ring true to you or do you do you see a
flaw in that line of
reasoning yeah so this this is an idea I
have grappled with a lot I think a lot
of people who passed through a kind
of uh
atheistic passage in life have had to
Grapple with it as well I remember being
something even going back to studying
philosophy in undergraduate school was
always a question which is if you
believe there's nothing to life but our
material existence that is finite that
we're born and then we die and that's
the end of everything there's no greater
power the challenge is how do you have
any kind of an Ethics or a morals that
make any sense if all there is is
materiality it seems like you could
justify being driven by nothing other
than material gain and no basis for any
kind of ethical or moral constraint
since that's what religion has typically
offered that there's a God that there's
a morality and an Ethics that they pass
down and if you remove that what is the
basis for this ethical code or for this
morality and I do think I even remember
when I was so sure of myself my early
20s being finding that a uncomfortable
and difficult question because it is not
an easy one to answer and I think as
I've gotten older I've also started
viewing spirituality and religion and I
kind of use that
interchangeably as necessary for a
complete human existence and I know that
has become the foundation for my own
ethics for my own morality the sense of
empathy and compassion that you have for
other people my view that that becomes a
necessity to honor that to be guided by
it and I do really wonder how it's
possible if you live your entire life
without that to avoid turning to
nihilism and I think a lot of people do
turn to nihilism when Western Society
tells them there is nothing spiritual or
religious that's valid and we see it in
all the mental health indexes as you
know better than anyone in terms of the
data You' studied and have talked a lot
about just kind of lack of purpose and
higher meaning that people are left with
in their lives when you strip away
everything other than material existence
yeah well the the materialist atheist
types I suppose would object and and I I
try to make the argument as powerful as
possible
that just because you come up with a
hypothetical practical necessity for a
certain kind of belief let's even call
it a certain kind of delusion or
Illusion right um that that doesn't
justify the hypothesis of something
Supernatural or Transcendent but I would
respond to that perhaps as follows the
first is is that we have some
relationship with the
whole and because we're a part of a
larger whole and we don't know what that
relationship is but there has to be some
relationship and I suppose your
relationship with that larger whole you
know existence as such could be positive
or negative and it's conceivable at
least that that's a decision of Faith
you know whether you're going to act in
accordance with the principle that being
itself is essentially good and to try to
understand from that what ethical
obligations that lays on you but I've
also been going through the biblical
Corpus trying to understand in some ways
what it means to believe
in
a Transcendent relationship and so I've
been writing about the story of Abraham
so let me just tell you what I've found
in that and you tell me what you think
about that
so what God is in the story of Abraham
is conceptualized as something like the
voice within that calls you to
Adventure so it it it's a proposition
right that there is a an animating
Spirit that's a good way of thinking
about it that can unite people
psychologically and
socially and that that uniting spirit
that uniting animating Spirit has a
canonical and immutable nature and one
of the manifestations of that nature is
the Call to Adventure and so Abraham is
an old man by the time he leaves his
father's tent but he hears a voice
within beckon to him that says you
should leave comfort and security and V
out into the world now it seems to me
that we do have a voice like that that
speaks within us so to speak and it's
not exactly our voice personally right
because it speaks to everyone so it
can't be something that's specifically
subjective and I think that you either
listen to that voice say and venture out
into the world in adventure or you don't
listen to it and either of those choices
is a choice of
faith and so that's a little different
than believing in a so-called like what
would you say a a hypothetical
Supernatural reality right it's more
like the decision to orient yourself
according to a certain animating
principle so in the story of Moses I'll
just develop it with one more story and
then leave it um The Same Spirit that
calls to
Abraham to embark on the adventure of
his life is the spirit that calls to
Moses to free his enslaved people from
tyranny and the hypothesis the biblical
hypothesis is those are manifestations
of the same Central animating Spirit
right that's yahwah in the Old Testament
so the hypothesis there is that there's
a Transcendent spirit that animates
humanity and one of its manifestations
is the Call to Adventure and another one
of its manifestations is the call to
resist tyranny and to move out of
what the domain of slavish habits and so
it seems to me that you either believe
in those propositions or you don't but
that either choice is a choice of Faith
right because you could say well tyranny
is acceptable and so is slavery that's a
decision of Faith or you could say that
tyranny is not acceptable and neither is
slavery and that's a decision of faith
and I don't see any non-faith
alternative and the same thing applies
on the adventure front so I don't know
what you think about that but maybe you
could make some comments and tell me you
know how that strikes you it's it is of
course the the challenge of this
conversation and you're absolutely right
the fact that there are positive
outcomes from believing something in
other words oh if you believe in
religion it's a lot easier to have a
foundation for a moral code doesn't make
that belief true there may be positive
benefits from it and it could be
completely false that of course is
logically true we're all with all these
questions though we're dealing with a
lack of dispositive proof even concrete
evidence empirical evidence of the kind
that we normally want when we're
deciding whether to affirm a belief but
that's true from all sides of this this
perspective if you want to believe
there's some Supernatural force greater
than yourself some force of the universe
whether it's a God or some other similar
concept of course you cannot provide
mathematical proof or anything close to
that but that's the same
for arguing it's negation you cannot
prove the absence of it either and I
this gets back to what I was saying
earlier about I think sometimes because
we are technologically advanced we Mis
we mistake that for being advanced in
other ways that all of our wisdom is
necessarily Superior to those who came
before us and at the end of the analysis
I do feel a certain kind of humility
when I look at the fact that human
beings for millennia across cultural
lines across religious lines have been
seeking the same sort of fulfillment the
same sort of purpose now maybe that's
just a psychological desire to believe
that life can't just be the 70 or 80 or
90 years when we're on the earth and
there's no purpose to it and we all kind
of deceive ourselves into believing
otherwise but my perceptions about all
of this ultimately can only be based in
my own personal experience and the
ability to connect with things that do
seem very clear to me to be a spiritual
presence a part of a whole a
Transcendent Force are things that just
feel very real to me didn't previously
because I can't prove them rationally
and I think in the gospel and the
stories you're referencing and there are
a lot of others one sees a similar
spirit in other religions as well you
know obviously people who believe in one
religion believe it's the True Religion
and the rest of the religions are by
definition false when I look at these
religious doctrine that have been around
for so long I see a lot more similarity
than I do differences or are obviously
dogmatic and doctrinal differences that
are important I think it's all about the
same human craving and the fact that we
all want this and need this and I think
so many people come to feel it I think
it takes a lot of arrogance just dismiss
that all the way as the byproduct of
Illusion or Superstition or deceit what
CH go ahead what changed for you like
why did you start why did this why did
this turn of attitude make itself known
to you what what happened in your life I
had a list of things when I was younger
I that I thought if I acquired them
would make me
happy and it was my conception of What
happiness is very much AR from Modern
Western culture tells you if you're
successful in your career if you become
financially prosperous if your work
becomes well
known these kinds of things are the
things that are going to ultimately be
fulfilling and the more I chase them and
the more I acquired them in a lot of
ways the less happy I
became
and
my husband I was married for 20 years my
husband died uh in May the this year so
just a couple of months ago um was
somebody who you know tried very hard to
get me to be open to other ways of
looking at the world including starting
a family you know adopting children from
an orphanage that would not have been
adopted had we not done so and we did
and that opened my eyes to the fact that
there's more to life than I had
previously thought I just became a lot
more humble once you once you see that
the way that you've been looking at the
world is incomplete or even on the wrong
path
you start believing that maybe there's
things you've written off before that
are things you ought to go back and
reconsider and then just being more open
to things like meditation and
spirituality um reading texts that are
derivative of Hinduism and um and then
even you know one time I think maybe 15
years ago I did just start down sit down
and read the gospel from start to finish
because it's something that you hear a
lot about you form opinions about and
then when you go and actually read it as
you've obviously been doing and have
done it is something that makes
you just connect to it in a different
way than if you're just looking at in
that snide dismissive way where a lot of
us are taught to view it and then once I
started traversing the spiritual path
and then seeing that real happiness and
fulfillment lies not in material gain or
fame or any of those things I mean there
are fulfilling things to
those things but you cannot be a
complete person I don't think without
family and then the spiritual component
and trying to understand where you fit
into this broader picture at least for
me that was the thing that finally
enabled me to be happy to be a complete
person and it just started forcing me to
reevaluate how I understood our place in
the world and our purpose in it right
okay so so we've proposed
that without something some
superordinate
orienting structure let's say that the
battle between good and evil collapses
into the political and that that poses
the danger of the rise of something
approximating totalitarianism often
justified by demonizing your enemies
let's say and also as a consequence of
willingness to use fear in the face of
the looming apocalypse and you've also
made the case
that there's a certain hubristic pride
in the censorship movement that is a
kind of intellectual Pride that is
predicated on the assumption that what I
know now is everything that's worth
knowing and that what other people think
can be easily dispensed with and then
the third thing we pointed to pointing
to the necessity of a metaphysics let's
say on the personal front in your
experience was has been that you pursued
some of the things that were more
materialistic and quite success
successfully that you were led to
believe or did believe would produce a
sense of continual fulfillment but what
you found in your life was that some
more traditional Ventures like starting
a family and some striving for something
Transcendent made itself known as
increasingly necessary as you got older
is that a fair summary of Where we've
gone so far
absolutely all right well let's let's
leave that for the time being I want to
return back to your line of of of of
books in 2008 you published a book
called Great American Hypocrites
toppling the big myths of Republican
politics so you're going after the
Republicans again you went after the
bush types for a good while and so what
did you conclude when you were
assessing the Republican political front
and why did you phrase it in terms of
hypocrisy and do you think there was
more hypocrisy for example on the
Republican side than there was on the
Democrat side if I'm being completely
honest and why wouldn't I be that book
is not a book that brings me a lot of
Pride I had I had actually I had just
started um writing about politics in
2000 late 2005 2006 and I wrote These
first two books that actually am proud
of I came from kind of a good place and
I was a constitution lawyer I moved to
Brazil I got married uh to my husband
and we had to live in Brazil we chose to
live in Brazil and I couldn't practice
law anymore and I need a way to kind of
make a living out of Journalism and at
the time writing books was the way I was
doing it there was a lot of pressure for
me so this
book there are some good ideas in this
book but the book itself the way it's
framed the title Great American
Hypocrites top toppling the big
Republican Party politics is very Bal
it's kind of tra it's a way more
partisan Trea than anything I've written
before or have written since but the
idea was that the there's a kind of
iconography in Republican Party politics
I remember when I was growing up my
father was mostly
conservative um but not fanatically
political and he used to kind of Revere
this certain sort of male archetype that
I think he felt was lacking in his life
like John Wayne Ronald Reagan Oliver
North um and I think Republican Party
politics has relied in a lot of ways on
these archetypes types often from people
who don't really exude those virtues in
their actual life people who purport to
be very Pious and yet in their private
life seems not to follow that very well
people who seek courage and strength by
sending other people to war but never
have been near a front line near a front
line themselves they like to send other
people to it and then kind of inflate
their chest and feel powerful so there
were some seeds of some substantive
ideas in the book but the editor just
wanted to kind of they were always
looking for the left's and culture and I
think the way that book got framed the
way they kind of forced me into this you
know attack the Republican party was
more a byproduct of that so I don't
think I've ever gone back and read that
book once it was done because it was
just kind of a a you know sort of Labor
of necessity rather than a labor of love
so well so so what do you think I mean
it's it your your comments on your book
are interesting and revealing I suppose
what is it that you you are
not particularly proud of in your words
in relationship to that work I mean
there's room on the journalistic front
for criticism of political opportunists
for example or of entire parties for
that matter and in some ways in many
ways you could regard that as the
appropriate purview of a critical
journalist so what do you think that
what do you think was wrong in your
approach you pointed maybe to uh what a
kind of instrumental necessity and and
what do you think it was that clouded
your vision let's say so that you're not
as happy with that book as you might be
about some of the other ones that you've
produced I think it's just the partisan
nature of it I think the critiques I
made are by no means confined to the
Republican party but book publishing
especially in politics kind of the
crudest way of trying to make a book
successful from a commercial perspective
is to feed a certain political camp
with material that will validate their
presuppositions will tell them that
they're on the right side so like I said
I do think the critiques were valid you
know hypocrisy of politicians also
though is a kind of loow hanging fruit I
think it didn't require a lot of brain
power to make that critique I don't
think it was particularly insightful I
do think there were some parts as I said
that were you know the seeds of some
interesting psychological it was a very
psychological book about how political
leaders try and create their imagery in
a way that's appealing
is is that to confine it to a critique
of the Republican party I think was just
a little bit cheap and like I said
probably the byproduct of commercial
pressures rather than intellectual
autonomy that's all I it's you know
there frul about to some degree you felt
like you had subverted your what higher
order critical capacity to Like
Instrumental necessity let's leave that
then let's go to the next one with
liberty and justice for some is this a
book you're more pleased with this was
2011 how the laws used to destroy
equality and protect the powerful okay
so now you've returned to something more
like a um what would you say an
orientation that you're that
you're well that that you feel allowed
you to remain firmly grounded while you
were writing this and you're looking
back on this book with with more
pleasure than on the previous book right
this book was a more systemic critique
it was not an any way partisan it I
think the origin of it was that you know
the first book that I wrote in 2006 you
mentioned how it a Patriot Act was a
legalistic critique of what I thought
were some law violating policies enacted
by the bush and Chen Administration
often without Congressional approval
sometimes in violation of congressional
statute I thought it was the kind of
criminality that would typically be
prosecuted and when President Obama was
inaugurated one of the first things he
did was announce this kind of amnesty
for any highlevel political officials or
anyone at the CIA who had broken the law
as part of the war on terror and invoke
what has now become this
traditional Elite serving framework that
Prosecuting people for crimes if they're
from a prior Administration or a prior
government is too destabilizing we have
to look forward not backward was the
phrase that he used it originated in
Gerald Ford's pardon of Richard Nixon
and what bothered me about it there was
no prosecutions of anyone on Wall Street
from the 2008 financial crisis even
though lots of Scholars have written
about why many prosecutions would have
been viable that was one of the most
cataclysmic events of our lifetime
certainly the 2008 financial crisis the
effects linger to this very day in terms
of people's economic stability all over
the world a lot of it was based on
fraudulent practices and you contrast
that with the fact the United States is
the
most uh Pro jail country on the planet
we have 5% of the world population and
yet 25% of prisoners on the planet are
in American prison we imprison people
for longer periods of time for crimes
that ordinarily would not be punished
this gargant prison state that
definitely disproportionately falls on
people who are at the lower end of the
socioeconomic perspective and so it was
kind of contrasting this idea that for
Elites there's a kind of legal immunity
and for poor people in the United States
who can't afford legal council who rely
on incredibly overwork
uh public defenders and the like people
go to prison for very long periods of
time including for nonviolent crimes
that have made the United States the
world's biggest Jailer and that contrast
has been disturbing to me and the book
was largely about that right so that's a
it sounds like a more classic left-wing
take I would say I'm still trying to
position you politically to some degree
I mean not that I have a particular
reason for doing so but I'm I it's one
of the questions we've Le left
unanswered is how you conceptualize your
political stance mean that that
opposition to law being formulated in a
manner that preferentially benefits the
wealthy because you use socioeconomic
status as the prime marker I mean that's
a continual
reasonable plaint from people on the
left right is that the P structures of
power get tilted in the service of those
who have the power and you know that's
something that everyone should always be
on a lookout for because just well if
for no other reason than just because
you have power right now doesn't mean
that you're going to have it you know in
a year so we should all watch out on
that front so what can you can you walk
through your your conclusions in that
book like what what did you see as the
causes you talked a little bit about the
proclivity of one Administration to
forgive the sins of the previous you
talked about the free pass that was
given to people who were involved in the
2008 financial Scandal are there
other what would you say are there other
threats to the Integrity of the law that
you see as particularly Germaine in the
US at the moment I mean I think I think
that book grew out of a concern that has
intensified in the last decade that the
West in general is now a society that
has a larger breach than ever before
between elites on the one hand and the
vast majority of people on the other you
referenced earlier for example the fact
that many of the views that are now
considered taboo or many of the beliefs
that are considered unworthy of being
aired or happen to be beliefs that
majorities of people uh subscribe to and
those prohibitions are being imposed by
an elite class that is so wildly at odds
with the vast majority of people over
whom they're essentially ruling which is
a very
destabilizing uh framework for a society
to have if you look for example at
polling data about crime and you listen
to Black or Latino elites on television
or people with newspaper columns you
would think that the vast majority of
non-white people want the police
defunded want the police deconstructed
hate the police don't want the police in
their neighborhoods of of course if you
look at polling data you find the exact
opposite is true black people Latinos
people any of any race who live in poor
communities either want the same amount
of police or more police in their
neighborhood there's this constant
breach obviously with gender ideology
there's that breach with a lot of
culture War issues with the question of
endless Warfare with the question of
gigantic corporations between the views
of the elite class and the views of the
vast majority people over whom they're
ruling and historically if you are to if
you were to look at how that breach has
been addressed there's essentially two
ways you can you can go about trying to
to resolve that namely you know I think
the election of Donald Trump the
election of Jer bonario in Brazil brexit
the rides of a lot of these kind of
populist parties are very much about the
fact that huge numbers of people feel I
think justifiably and validly that Elite
ideology doesn't care about them at all
is willing to squeeze every opportunity
out of their life in order to benefit a
small minority of people and when you
have this kind of mass populist anger
traditionally the elites can try and
appease it by kind of throwing some more
crumbs to people just to keep them just
satiated enough that they're not going
to go out into the street and cause
political turmoil and protest on the
lake or the society can say you know
what let them Riot we'll just militarize
to the teeth we'll give ourselves every
kind of power and every kind of
authoritarian uh weapon that we need so
that even if they want to Riot they'll
be crushed immediately I think the West
is choosing that latter path of no
longer trying to appease people no
longer trying to give them enough to
keep them at a
decent uh quality of life or the
perception that the system is
essentially fair and instead is param
militarizing is becoming more
authoritarianism I think that's a lot of
the trends in the west are about and
that book was really a way of saying
that even the law the kind of Lynch pin
of what is supposed to ultimately
guarantee that even though we were
supposed to have material differences
the founders were capitalists they
expected and anticipated that there
would be differences in material wealth
that the law would ultimately be the
guarantor of the fairness of that
inequality that people would accept its
validity or its legitimacy because we
were all operating by the same set of
rules and increasingly the law has
become something that's the exact
opposite just yet another weapon for
Elites to use against uh people who are
powerless to keep them in line to keep
them kind of uh neutered and Toothless
and that's really the this the the the
ethos out of which that book grew and
the fact that Elites have given
themselves a kind of broadscale immunity
that our prisons and our courtrooms or
criminal courtrooms aren't for wealthy
people aren't for powerful people with
some exceptions but are overwhelmingly
for poor people even and once you are
addicted to drugs committing nonviolent
crimes that was the critique of of that
book so let's segue from that into your
2014 book that's no place to hide Edward
Snowden the NSA and the US surveillance
State and so well that obviously
developed some of the themes that you
were just discussing which is the
proclivity of the elite and I have some
questions about who you think the elite
are exactly because that's an
interesting issue um tell me what you
discovered and what you were attempting
to accomplish with no place to hide that
basically told the story of the work I
did with Edward Snowden he had contacted
me anonymously at the end of
2012 saying he had access to a huge
Trove of top secret documents that
demonstrated that the US government its
allies were engaged in a kind of
ubiquitous surveillance that would shock
people even such as myself who had been
writing about that and had belongs to
suspected that was the case uh the kind
of final straw for him was when he heard
James Clapper President Obama's senior
National Security official who was the
director of National Intelligence
testified before the senate in early
2013 he was asked by Senator Ron weiden
of Oregon does the NSA collect dossier
on millions and millions of Americans
and James Clapper lied and said no sir
it does not not wittingly and Snowden
had in his hands the EV evidence because
he had worked for for CIA and then the
the NSA as a contractor the evidence
proving that what Clapper denied the NSA
was doing was in fact exactly what the
NSA was doing in fact to an extent that
nobody would have suspected the model of
the NSA was collected all they really
wanted to and were well on their way to
converting the internet into a tool of
ubiquitous surveillance that everything
done on the internet set on the Internet
by Ordinary People American citizens
suspected of no wrongdoing these were
suspicionless this was suspicionless
surveillance uh was being collected and
stored with the potential when they
wanted to analyze and utilize this
information incredibly comprehensive
pictures of Our Lives based on who we
were speaking to what we were reading um
the content of our communication and so
I went to Hong Kong met was Snowden
along with the filmmaker War pess who
filmed it that became the film that
became the film that won the Oscar in
2015 for best documentary citizen 4 very
kind kind of high drama but I think
journalistically
consequential and to me that's what that
those materials revealed was just how
unaccountable the US Security State had
become that this was a part of our
government that was created to operating
complete secrecy but it was always
supposed to be attached to some form of
democratic accountability there were
lots of abuses discovered in the mid
'70s there were supposedly reforms done
and yet we have a part of our government
that is now huger than ever more
powerful than ever operat so much in the
dark that I was getting contacted when
we were doing this reporting by members
of Congress who are on the intelligence
Committee in the US in Great Britain in
Australia and Canada saying I had no
idea any of this was taking place and it
was kind of a radicalizing moment for me
because it wasn't for me a book or an
episode in my life that was about
surveillance and privacy although of
course it was about that as much as it
was about democracy the fact that these
incredibly consequential choices had
been undertaken about how the government
was going to utilize the internet
converted into a system of mass
indiscriminate ubiquitous surveillance
with no Democratic accountability of any
kind no transparency of any kind and it
made me realize that there really is
this kind of part of the government as
Dwight Eisenhower tried to warn us about
in
1961 before Vietnam before the war on
terror that essentially is the real
government is the government that is
immune to
elections that does what it wants with
very little
constraints and I find it very very
alarming very
menacing and well and how do you feel
about that now I mean do do you think
we're farther down the rabbit hole than
we were when you wrote that book I mean
it's N9 years later and our
technological reach has expanded
tremendously I mean when you're looking
at the state of Freedom let's say in the
west
today what are your what are your
observations on that
front I actually think it's worse um
which might be paradoxical because there
were some benefits from this reporting
it made people aware for the first time
of not only the extent to which the US
government and its allies are spying on
again not Al-Qaeda cells or uh Isis
cells which everybody would support but
entire Western population including
American citizens and that awareness
made it possible to take precautions
against it so people use encryption more
than they did before big tech companies
like Facebook and Google were pressure
to demonstrate they were protecting the
safe the privacy of their users by also
using encryption so it did construct
some barriers to what the government had
been doing but one of the interesting
thing was at the time we did the sowden
reporting you're talking
2013 the fear that had once been
inspired by the mention of al-Qaeda had
really worn off this is now 12 years
years after the 911 attack there had
been no mass casualty terrorist attacks
in the United States anywhere near 911
even the ones that had happened quickly
in Madrid and in London and the years
following those kind hadn't happened and
so there was a sense that okay the war
and Terror has gone way too far this is
kind of an extremism that we should not
tolerate and then very quickly Isis
emerged in 2014 and 2015 Isis was
presented as this threat worse than
Al-Qaeda and then 2016 in the 2016
election suddenly Russia got kind of
revitalized as the existential threat
that America and the West faces brexit
was blamed on Russia Trump's election
was blamed on Russia and it reinstalled
this instilled this kind of sense that
no we actually like the CIA we like the
US Security State we believe it needs to
kind of operate Without Limits because
the enemies we're facing are so great
and that was going back to what we
talked earlier about how people had been
convinced to think about Trump they also
began thinking of that about Vladimir
Putin and Russia even though American
presidents from Clinton to Bush to Obama
to Trump had talked about Putin as this
kind of rational figure with whom they
could do business suddenly got converted
into this the new
Hitler and this ability of the US
Security State and its allies in the
media to always give people this new
frightening enemy that convinces them
that they need to acquas to
authoritarian Powers is almost
impressive and the way in which American
liberals in particular the Democratic
party started feeding on this hatred for
Russia and this belief that Vladimir
Putin was this kind of hitler-like
figure along with Donald Trump pushed
them into the arms of these agencies
because they perceived correctly that
these agencies were trying to sabotage
the Trump presidency this is where
Russia gate came from it was a CIA
concoction they fed it every day to the
New York Times And The Washington Post
which gave themselves poit serves for it
it re vitalize these fears and I think
these agencies and I don't just think if
you look at polling data you'll see they
are held in higher regard than in any
time since the peak of the Cold War
particularly by adherence of the
democratic party I think one of the best
things that Donald Trump did was Usher
in a kind of
skepticism about these agencies that had
never previously gotten a foothold in
mainstream Republican Party politics
before but for exactly that reason the
establishment wing of politics and media
and the Democratic party views this agen
these agencies as more benevolent than
ever and that is a a really alarming
mindset you
tweeted and this might be relevant well
it's relevant to what you just said but
it might also be relevant to maybe what
we'll close this discussion with which
is how do you characterize this Elite
let's say that things are being done in
service of so you tweeted out
the cultural left meaning the part of
the left focused on cultural issues
rather than imperialism or
corporatism has become increasingly
censorious moralizing controlling
repressive petulant joyless self
victimizing trivial and Status Quo
perpetuating now I've had the
opportunity to ask 20 or
30 congressmen and Senators on the
Democrat side
when they think the left goes too far
and I asked Robert F Kennedy that
actually in our interview and that was
the one question he declined to answer
saying that he wanted to put forward a
vision of unity especially on the
Democrat side rather than disunity you
know and fair enough but I've been
struck by the fact that the Democrats in
particular can't see the danger of their
radical Fringe and seem utterly
unwilling or unable ble to dissociate
them from what I see as behind the mean
by behind the
scenes manipulators with an almost
Psychopathic bent um that's the
increasingly censorious moralizing
controlling repressive petulent crowd
you talked a fair bit about the elites
today you know and the the elite um from
the leftist perspective is historically
being those who are wealthy or who
occupy higher positions on the
socioeconomic ladder but it isn't
exactly obvious that the elite on the
left are characterized by those
descriptors precisely mean when you're
trying to
conceptualize who constitutes the
censorious tyrants or this increasingly
repressive
Force what what do you conclude
what where exactly is the are the
enemies of Freedom so to speak the
enemies of free speech at least let's
say where do you think they're primarily
located and and does this is there a new
conceptualization necessary that makes a
mockery of the old political
divisions yeah you know this term Elite
you're absolutely right to interrogate
this it is it is obviously a somewhat
ambiguous term and that ambiguity
sometimes allow allows a kind of
Reckless use it you just throw that word
around you're not really sure exactly to
whom you're referring it almost has this
kind of like uh melodramatic lure to it
like oh we're always against the elites
everybody we just like is the elite and
so I think it is important to ask that
question and have at least a concrete
sense of who you're talking about I
think it maybe even
differs based on what kind of policy
debate you're having so maybe the elite
is a little bit different when you're
talking about Economic Policy where I
think
probably the large corporate power cares
most about economic policy and uses
their weight and throws their weight
around most there the T code and
Regulation and things of that kind then
you have a kind of foreign policy Elite
that has some overlap with that but
probably is different in a way as well
and then you're talking about the
culture War you know the cultural kind
of debates that increasingly I think
unfortunately have come to dominate our
discourse and in large part it's because
the left has prioritized
the culture War if you go and watch left
wiing YouTube shows the most popular
ones or read uh or listen to leeling
podcast which I do it's part of my job
and I think you know it's necessary for
me to kind of stay in touch with every
political sector the extent to which the
culture more generally and gender
ideology and trans issues in particular
received the bulk of the attention is
almost shocking to me I mean left wiing
politics traditionally in the 20th
century was about opposing imperialism
and militarism and corporatism and
oligarchy and now there's almost none of
that I mean there's on the left you
wouldn't even know there's a war in
Ukraine you wouldn't even know there's a
foreign policy that is almost entirely
ignored in favor of this kind of
fixation on trans issues and gender
ideology right now one of the longest
standing and biggest leeling YouTube
shows The Young Turks is in the process
of being utterly decimated and cancelled
and had views over the years that from a
left Ling perspective are completely
anathema but since they're about war
they love matal and
Albright no one cares about that they're
being canceled because they cross the
one line you can't cross on the left
which is questioning some of the most
outer fringes of extremism trans
ideology including whether or not
biological men should be able to compete
in women's sports whether puberty
blockers are safe for children where
even in northern Europe they're debating
those
things and the intolerance for or any
kind of vibrant questioning or dissent
even from people who you know say I
think trans adults should be able to
live their lives with total dignity with
full legal rights that's nowhere near
enough you have to affirm every last uh
element of that agenda in order to even
be deemed acceptable it is incredibly
repressive and I think at the end of the
day when you talking about who the elite
is it's kind of on the one hand a vague
term but it's also not that ult to
identify who it's the views that are
permitted and the views that are
suppressed and if your views are among
the views that are
supressed that's a pretty good
indication that you are not in the elite
you you seem to be making a well you
seem to be making I I would say a
twofold categorization on on the one
hand we have what we've always had and
which and it's something that always
poses a threat to the Integrity
of states that have to continually adapt
which is the the tendency of those who
have been successful
economically to bend and distort the
system in a manner that supports their
continued
hegemony independent of their continued
productive activity and I I kind of
think about that in general as the
problem of outof control gigantism and
you can see that on the government front
just as much as on the corporate front
you know famously in 2008 the Mantra was
too big to fil
and I always thought that the maner
should have been so big you will
certainly fail and then there's this
additional element that you point to and
use the example of what's happening to
The Young Turks at the moment on the
gender front pointing out that there's a
an elite that are possessed by a set of
ideological ideas that have degenerated
in recent years into an almost
monomaniacal fixation on gender and
identity and then there's some Unholy
alliance between the two you know which
which which I don't quite understand um
although it seems to be manifesting
itself you know it's it's a variant
perhaps of
the willingness of the coercive left not
that the rightwing was like without
error error on this front to Ally
themselves for example with big Pharma
and as you pointed out to
increasingly adopt a positive attitude
toward the
very secretive and background gigantic
government operations that the left
would have been historically opposed to
so I don't understand the alliance
exactly like I don't exactly understand
how the ideological possession that
manifests itself as emphasis on the
Primacy of group identity can be in bed
with the people who are using their
economic power on the regulatory capture
front maybe it's something like maybe
you see something like this on the ESG
front a is where the the power elite so
that would be Larry fank and the black
rock types are willing to use the
moralistic ideology of the radical left
to hide their what to hide their guilt
and to hide their mashin naations on the
power front is that a reasonable way of
construing it I'm so glad we're we're
talking at this at the end here because
it's so fundamental to these changes in
in the political landscape the fact that
you for example were censored by Google
while you're interviewing RFK Jr and
have been censored before and people who
believe what you believe on the question
of trans ideology and gender ideology
are censored routinely by Google and
Facebook and the pre- Elon regime of
Twitter whereas nobody would ever be
censored by big tech for being as
Extreme as you want to be on trans
issues urging that 12-year-olds be uh
given puberty blockers or that young
girls get masectomy the minute that they
decide that they're dysphoric obviously
no one's getting censored for being on
that side of the debate you see the
manifestation of the elite there so
suddenly you are this leftwing culture
Warrior who likes to think that you're
antagonistic to Capital and yet the
largest and richest corporations are
completely on your side on these debates
in fact they're your enforcers yeah I
noticed this for the first time when we
right after we did the snow in reporting
in 2015 so it was about two years after
it began the British version of the NSA
which is the
gchq really probably the most extremist
in this five eyes Alliance they're sort
of the ones that do the things that not
even the NSA will do when they can't go
far enough under the law or ethics the
gchq steps up and do it does it in 2015
they bathed their futuristic
headquarters in the colors of the
rainbow flag declared lgbtq day
apologize for their treatment of some of
the gay code Breakers including Allen
tur during World War II and then
suddenly began embracing the left's
cultural agenda now the CIA does it the
FBI does it they all celebrate women's
day and LGBT day and every one of the in
corporations obviously do it too and
therein you can see exactly what these
institutions of power perceive as in
their Interest Who to side with and who
not to side with and you know you look
at who gets censored you look at who
corporations are endorsing what these
institutions of militarism and
surveillance are the the flags they're
waving and the ones they're not waving
and it's not difficult to see what is a
lead opinion and what isn't and whether
it's because it's cynical maybe there is
part of that like oh we know if we wave
the rainbow flag and we're the CIA that
will get the left to embrace us more or
whether it's just the fact that the new
Elite leaders in Western institutions of
authority have become True Believers of
these causes probably some division of
bold ultimately it doesn't matter the
fact of the matter is that establishment
power including capital is on the side
of the left in the culture war and as a
result they have become this kind of
bullying faction that no longer really
opposes large scale financial
institutions or corporate power or or
militaristic power because they perceive
correctly they're on their side and
they're their allies well I think that's
probably a good place to end you know we
we managed to tie things together there
at the end I mean I guess I would maybe
I'll add one more comment you know it it
struck
me that the best camouflage for
Psychopathic manipulators and those are
PE those are people who will do anything
instrumental to advance their own narrow
self-interest um a well documented group
let's say on the psychometric and
psychological front the best camouflage
for assiduous instrumental
self-promoters who are willing to
manipulate others say using fear and to
acrw power to themselves
is compassion is the guise of compassion
you know and what that means too is that
the the that corporate male feance can
cover itself up by allying itself with
the useful idiots of the compassionate
left and and I don't mean the people who
are using compassion necessarily on the
left as a manipulation in and of itself
I think there are plenty of people who
do that but the people who are naive
enough to assume that a show of
compassion means the real thing and the
fact that those enablers exist and I
think the Democrats by the way are rif
with such people means that the real
manipulators at the levels of um
operating at the levels of undeserved
and untar corporate power governmental
power for that matter can manipulate
entire populations by claiming to be
compassionate while going about their
normal business which is the acrel of
power to themselves and I think that
accounts for that Unholy Alliance you
know and that strange alliance between
because it is a strange alliance between
the the
left which historically in its best
manifestations did provide a voice for
the dispossessed for the Unholy alliance
between the modern left and the
corporate and gigantic
government well between the corporations
and the gigantic and the gigantic forces
of government and media so
that seems to be where we're at now and
it's not it's not obvious how you
conceptualize that or oppose it within
the confines of the classic divisions
between right and left right it's a
whole new landscape that's presenting
itself to us and it seems to require new
conceptualizations exactly I mean you
know that's why I think there's
confusion sometimes about my ideology
and others ideology the Atlantic just
called RFK Jr the first MAA Democrat
whereas you know when when RFK Jr is
critiquing a lot of the uh institutions
that had long been the primary targets
of the left including the US Security
State and big Pharma and the US war
machine but now that codes his right wi
I also think to just add very quickly to
what you said as as the kind of just to
tie it all together is I think identity
politics is used very similarly to how
you just described the social justice
causes and the way that they're uh
cynically uh
employed by these institutions the power
to give the appearance that they're on
the side of the left and they become
actual allies of the left obviously if
you just change demographically the
people who are running these
institutions so that now you have a
black woman who's in general or you have
a latino man who's the CFO of a major
corporation it casts the appearance that
there's been some kind of a radical
change for those casually looking when
in reality it's just kind of the the
costume that they're Dawning in order to
continue doing exactly what they're
doing and just to win new supporters and
it's incredibly effective because
ultimately so many people are satisfied
with the most superficial of changes and
are willing to embrace and cheer any
institutions of authority as being their
allies even though they're continuing to
do those things that they always have
done when they were once their animes
and that is exactly what is causing this
new political
landscape hey well you know that seems
like a very good place to end so for
everybody watching and listening I'm
going to talk to Glenn for another half
an hour on the daily wire plus side
we'll conduct some investigation into
the manner in which the interests that
he's displayed fairly consistent
interests really over what almost uh
it's it's a long period of time now 30
years really pretty consistent interests
in um protection of free speech for
example that looks like it's your
Paramount concern and then Associated
interest of All Sorts on the political
and cultural front so we'll delve into
the Genesis of those um preoccupations
on The Daily wire plus side and if
you're inclined to go over there and and
have a listen or a watch you know that
that might be useful for you and
productive for us um as Glenn mentioned
and I mentioned during this podcast
YouTube has been on our case to a fairly
intense degree in the last couple of
months U me to some degree because
they've censored three of my podcasts
and I suspect will censor a number of
the other ones that I have in the camp
um and really gone after a number of the
people that I'm working with or
alongside of at least um at the
dailywire plus so if you're inclined to
throw them some support this is probably
not such a bad time to do it in any case
we're going to head over there thank you
to the film crew here in Northern
Ontario for facilitating this and Glenn
for talking to me today and for sharing
what you've been investigating with
everybody watching and listening and to
everyone who is watching and listening
thank you very much and uh
well we'll see you on the next podcast
thanks Glenn thank you appreciate
[Music]
it